Her low freak bitches.
Yeah.
I've spent a year on porn sets,
pain research, most research
it did, it was a low,
my wife did say to me once or twice,
he really liked you really have to
go to another pawn. So, uh, it, uh,
I've just made,
I've just finished making a series for
audible called the butterfly effect.
And the flap of the butterfly's wings,
which I'm tracing throughout
the series is, um,
is this young man called baby in a
WHO's like a tech nerd in Brussels.
And he has the idea to get rich
from giving the world free porn.
So free streaming porn.
So the series is about the kind of tech
takeover of porn in the valley. Uh,
I'm already real, oh no, this one's
everywhere. Yeah, no, that was back,
that was back in the day. That
was like in the 90s. So Fabian,
Fabian gave the world pornhub
okay. Uh, and friction. No,
no, this is, this is all true.
So, okay, let me go back.
So in the 90s,
this kid called Fabian good.
Like Fabian Tillman as a young boy
in Brussels, like a tech nerd. Uh,
would like go and compuserve and swap
porn passwords, porn for free like this,
which is how people got porn
for free back in the 90s. Um,
and then it, he had like a sort
of Eureka moment, which is I can,
I can give the world youtube for porn.
Right?
So he brought up this fledgling
company in Montreal Code, uh,
um,
it was called Mansef at the time.
It was run by these two brothers up
in Montreal and they had just invented
pornhub.
Uh,
Fabian bought up porn hub and then kind
of overnight singlehandedly took over
the valley. Uh, there, it's
an extraordinary story.
This massive flow of money went
from where we are now in the valley.
A community of people who were
making pretty good money from porn.
The money flowed into Fabian's pocket.
Uh, cause what Fabian
did was, um, well look,
if you're, if you're a porn star
and you go to a bank and say,
can I have a checking account? She, a
porn star or a porn star upon, well,
I said a porn star,
but actually aren't brilliant many porn
stars anymore of your porn person. Uh,
and you go to a bank and say,
can I have a checking account?
The bank manager will usually
say no because you're in porn,
which means your disreputable really yes.
People,
people like story.
I've written about this a lot about how
they find it very hard to get mortgages
have the kind of hard to get
checking accounts, checking accounts.
That seems unlikely. I mean I would
believe that may be mortgages.
They would think that your,
your business is fairly unstable.
That kind of makes sense
as far as investments in
concern and also the idea that
other people,
other customers might not like the
idea that they're high street bank is,
is being shared with somebody
who's in porn. I've really, yeah,
it's called reputational risk. Wow.
That seems really dumb to me. Yeah.
I'm going to make any sense
at all. Right. Well, sure. Um,
but Fabian was making money from running
a site that doubt in the UN in piracy.
So basically funds would upload,
um,
porn illegally onto pornhub.
So Fabian was running the site that
was filled with pirated content.
Uh, Fabian went to a bank
to say I want to expand,
but because he wasn't
extensively a porn person,
he was a tech person who was
deemed to be respectable.
This bank gave him a $362
million loan to expand,
uh, to build an empire based in
part on the handling of stolen porn.
So we went to the valet who will,
who will already kind of paranoid they're
all that porn was being stolen and put
up onto porn hub and he bought up all the,
you know,
loads of companies that cut price because
the companies were like panicking.
I wanted to sell.
I'm certainly Fabian just single
handedly like took her off upon. Um,
so I wanna I nobody cares about that.
Nobody was thinking about the consequences
of that because Fabian was giving the
world what they wanted,
which was free porn. Um,
but I was really curious to know like,
well, what were, let me pause there.
You said no one cares about it.
No, but a lot of people did.
It was a huge issue and there was a lot
of like moral debate around with it.
Well be,
you know,
there's a lot of the girls that were in
porn that were really pissed off because
they weren't making any
money anymore and they were,
there was a lot of social
media posts about it,
imploring people to stop
using these sites, which you
know, and listen to. Exactly.
People cat, you know, porn consumers
didn't care. Well it was uh,
it was an interesting tech,
like a moral tech debate that was going
on for awhile. But the debate is lost.
I mean there was a,
um,
it's really interesting cause there was
a guy who lived down the street from me
and he was a big time porn producer and a,
I actually knew him from my Jujitsu class
and he was a real high role in sort of
character.
Like he always had this beautiful
Mercedes Benz and he wore these really big
watches, a lot of, you know,
fancy clothes and he was just making
just tons of money and he had this
beautiful house and he was just this ball
or character and then it all dried up,
dried up quick. Yeah, it went,
it went into, he lost his house.
His house got repossessed.
Yeah.
And Fabian got so rich because of this,
because the money went from the
offense pocket into Fabian's pocket.
Fabian got so rich. Oh, how's he
getting rich off of free streaming?
So the ads it because,
because of ads,
but partly because he bought up the
paid sites as well. So you know,
because the paid sites were like panicking
because they were losing all their
money to piracy. So brought up the
competition. He bought it red tube.
He bought at Youporn say bought up
all the competition to porn hub.
Ariosa bought loads of paid sites,
playboy TV.
So your friend got so poor
that his house got repossessed.
Fabian got so rich that he installed in
his house and aquarium that was so big
that it diver had to come every week
and dive in and clean the coral reef for
no, you're doing well when you get
your own diver. That's weird. Yeah.
So yeah, you're right.
Porn people cared a lot,
but the outside world didn't
care because you know,
the outside world doesn't care
where music's getting pirated.
So they sure as hell don't
care when it's pawn. Well,
they care a little bit
about the music thing,
but the porn thing got almost no traction.
And when the porn industry essentially
for the most part collapsed,
or at least there was a
massive amount of loss,
there was no talk about like some sort
of a bailout or anything silly like that.
I was like, no, that industry's
gone. Right. You know,
act like many other
industries were bailed out.
And when you look at that hair smaller,
right?
When you look at their headquarters up
in Montreal or the company that owned
porn, it's not porn, it's
techie. So your work,
and Fabian actually said to me
quite telling Lee, he said yes.
He said it was amazing.
You wouldn't even know that we were in
porn unless you went to the wrong floor.
Now he seems like a guy who's
well aware of his crime.
Yeah. I mean Fabian would say, if it
wasn't me, it would be somebody else.
What does that mean?
Um,
and it sounds like a good thing to say
after you kill somebody. I did say, um,
it's progress. He call it progress,
but it's that he's a criminal.
I mean it's, it's essentially he's lucky
that he's dealing in pirated stuff,
right? The one tag, Fabian
got annoyed with me.
He was quite game like I wanted to,
I wanted to interview him and then I
wanted to travel to the valley to look at
the consequences and trace
consequence through to consequence.
Like where would I end up if I just,
cause I think people don't think about
consequences on the Internet that much.
They want to just, you know, destroy
somebody and then carry on with their day.
So I want to tell the story about
consequences that the only time Fabian got
annoyed with me was when,
um,
either me or Mike Quasar
director said to him, you know,
you uploaded pirated porn.
And he said, no, I didn't.
I've never uploaded pirated porn.
I offer a surface in which of the
people can upload pirated porn.
And if they tell us to take it down,
we'll take it down.
Which is have to find it,
they have to find it.
And also there's so much fucking free
porn and porn that it's like cutting down
the forest with a butter knife. It's
impossible to yeah, yeah. No, you can,
you can say tech down in my
power to support and they'll
say, okay, sorry. Fine.
But then there's like a million other
people's report up there anyway. Um, yeah,
so, uh, actually it's
pretty, I don't, by the way,
what I'm about to say shouldn't be
construed as me saying that I think that
Fabian has a psychopath because I don't,
but that thing about not taking
responsibility for your own actions,
I just remembered a lot of book few
years ago about psychopaths called the
psychopath test and a psychopathic trait
is that like if somebody kills somebody
in a bar, they would say, well, it's
his fault for looking at me. Funny.
So failure to accept responsibility for
our own actions is one of the 20 items
on the psychopath.
Jack,
do you think he is a psychopath or
do you think it's some sort of a con
convenient neglecting of certain
responsibility for what happened?
He,
I don't think Fabian,
that was very much a tangential thing
cause I don't think Fabian is a psychopath
at all. But, um,
I think that tech people have created
a sort of a moral bubble around
themselves. I'd talked to the head
of a porn hub's mobile division.
So if you have, if you've ever
watched, he's called Brandon.
If you've ever watched a porn hub on
your mobile, you have Brandon to thank.
And I said to Brandon, Brandon said, like,
we never like 99% of porn hub
employees never set foot on a porn set.
Uh, and he said, that's good because
you know, we're designing, you know,
we searched engine people were, you
know, we all want to say it would be a,
it would be sort of unpleasant
to set foot on a porn set.
It would be sort of intimidating and
unpleasant. Uh, and I said, well, maybe,
maybe it would have
been good if more porn,
her people did set foot on porn sets
because you would be able to see the
negative consequences of your
business plan. And Brandon went
their livelihood, which again, is
a very tacky thing to say, right.
Because it's all about, it's all about
progress, their livelihood. Yeah.
What does you mean by that? Like, okay,
now you want to talk about their
livelihood, their livelihood people,
they're essentially like
a content provider that's
not paying for any content.
Yeah. And um, yeah, so, uh,
yeah, I just remembered a guy called
David Lowery who's a, who's a, um,
uh, he's, he's interested in kind
of piracy issue in, in music.
And he said,
when we look back on the
dystopian movies of the 1930s,
when,
you know,
machines will take over like metropolis
or something like the moral of the film,
like the climax of the film is
when the people, the humans, uh,
defeat say, you know, I, we're not going
to live in a world run by machines.
We're going to defeat the machines
and human morality or takeover.
But now that machines
are ruling the world, um,
instead of us defeating the machines,
we are adapting our morality to fit
in with the machines capability.
So because it is easy to pirate,
instead of saying let's not pirate,
we're just adapting a morality and saying,
okay and we can watch pirated porn.
It's fine.
Yeah.
But it's not as simple as pirating because
pirating is what everybody does on,
you know when, when they're sharing it
through message boards or what have you.
That's sort of pirating right when
they're uploading it to these websites and
servers and stuff.
But what,
what he's doing is massively
profiting off of other people's work.
It's a little bit of a more of
a gray area. Yeah, I'd say so.
He's not even gray kind of dark when he
sent and they profited hugely from other
people piloting their favorite porn
films onto his side. Has he been sued?
Uh, he got into, he got
arrested for tax evasion. Uh,
and that's how he got out
of the business eventually.
But I think that will go up.
That all got solved.
I'm not sure if he ever got sued like,
cause if somebody says to him,
if somebody said to him that take down
my, my, you know, bad babysitters,
volume two is mine.
I say that because I was actually on
the set of bad babysitters volume two,
he tell. Sure. Yeah, sorry, of
course. And it would go down,
but then maybe somebody else would
put it up later that day or you know,
and it didn't matter because
everything else was very, uh,
I tell you one amazing consequence
of all of this though. Um,
so what I wanted to do, and
this audible series, uh,
the butterfly effect was to kind of trace
the consequences of this lie. You know,
what was the tornadoes
that were being created.
And one amazing consequence is like Fabian
surrounded himself with a tech wizard
slap people who knew how
the Internet worked, uh,
including a lot of search engine people.
So instead of making porn films
like they made in the 90s,
this porn director,
Mike Quasar,
I said to me that the first film he ever
made back in the 90s was called women
of influence.
Uh,
now all the porn films have
to be easily searchable. It's,
it's like a kind of arms race
of search engine optimization,
like to get yourself up
the Google rankings. Uh,
so all the porn films in the valley
aren't called women of influence.
Cause how do you search for that?
They're there.
They basically see what the most popular
search terms are and then make films
based on that.
So Mike Quasar was telling me this on
the set of the film he was shooting that
day, which was stepdaughter
cheerleader orgy. So I said,
so I said to her, just, it was just around
the corner from here. So I said to Mike,
so are there,
cause I thought about like women of
influence versus stepdaughter cheerleader
orgy. Uh, I'd look,
I haven't seen women of influence.
So for all I know the model of women
of influences that women shouldn't have
influenced,
but my guess is that women of influence
as a more kind of holistic poured,
filmed and stepdaughter cheerleader orgy.
So I said to Mike Other,
any people in the valley who like,
can't get work because they're
just not a keyword. And My,
yeah,
like every at home porn
actress now between the ages
of 23 and 29 can't get work
because they're not a
teen and then not a MILF.
They're like in this sort
of fallow periods between
teen and MILF when that just
attractive and just attractive
isn't a searchable term.
So if you're not a teen
and you're not a male,
if you're like a 26 year old adult
film actress, you can't get work.
You just have to lie. Well, I
said to Mike, what do you do?
Do you just like sit there until you lay,
become a milf and become employable
again and uh, the answers,
they have to find other
ways to make money.
So escorting is going through
the roof in the valley. Uh, yeah,
because if the tech,
because people like Fabian because of
the tech takeover of pawn escort since
going through the roof,
but also another thing that's going
through the roof is this kind of weirdly
adorable world of bespoke porn. Yeah.
And that's what the article will,
what was the, uh, um, publication who
published that article was the Guardian.
I did like a written version of
one of the episodes. If there's,
if the show I just stumbled upon it,
you know,
knowing that you were going to be here,
I didn't even know you wrote it.
I was reading it and as I was reading it,
I was like, oh, John wrote this. Right.
What an amazing, did you
know about this world? No.
And Rye in porn land here in the valley.
So yeah,
it's a pretty hidden salt.
Fascinating. Explain what it is.
Like people literally will request some
of the most bizarre things and these
people will make custom films based
on their weird kinks just for them,
like a team of professional porn people.
Uh,
because the valley's suffering so much
because there's porn happened. So on,
we'll make an entire porn
film just for you now.
How much does something like this cost?
Like say if you want to make a film
about girls were in Newton Ninja turtle
outfits who kicked guys in the balls.
That's entirely possible, right? Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Anything's possible.
But that sounds like something that might
actually sell at the, yeah. Oh yeah. Uh,
they that like a couple of
thousand dollars. That's it.
Yeah. Couple grand. Yeah.
Wow.
Okay.